well we've got this rosetta spacecraft
it's arrived at a comet it's looking
down at a comment about 100 kilometers
above a comet called comet 67p there's
no need for a comet and it's its
orbiting a comet and actually it's not
orbiting in a circle which I think's
quite neat one of the things that it's
doing is its orbiting in a sort of
triangle because the gravity I had
associated with the comet is so so small
that actually it doesn't have the pull
to keep the spacecraft in orbit in a
circular orbit so they're having to turn
on the Rockets on the spacecraft to sort
of turn it round the corner of the
triangle let it's like Sir Isaac through
his work Newton's first law shoots down
to the next corner and then it comes
around so it's just going around this
comet it's now about five four hundred
five million kilometers from Earth it's
the Comets heading towards the you know
an orbit that goes around the Sun it's
currently between I think about Mars and
Jupiter and so it's remarkable right
this thing has traveled all that way
it's actually traveled something like
six billion kilometers in order to get
there the way it had to use gravity of
the Sun use gravity of the earth user
gravity of Mars in order to accelerate
itself out to this fast if distance run
and then it's had to slow itself down so
that it's now traveling to within about
I think it's something like one meter
per second of the comet itself which
which itself is traveling at a mere
55,000 kilometers per hour pulled up
alongside but is 100 kilometers up and
is just now going around it and and will
gradually over the next few months work
its way down I think it's going to do
it's going to go down to its hoping to
go down to a 50 kilometer and orbit and
then if it can it's going to think
they've got to keep checking if they'll
have no idea what what it's like down
there then so then they're going to
triangle down I think to up 30
kilometers and look around and now now
they're going to look for places where
they've got a
Lander on the spacecraft that they're
going to then fire down to the tool and
somewhere on the comet so they're going
to try and decide where's the best place
to land if they can even land it down
there of course and the idea is to try
and understand what the Comets made of
what's what's in it it
comets are thought of as they've got
this mystical image about them you know
when you look in the sky in those
beautiful tales and they you know
they're made of ice and dust and then
days gone by they're associated with
usually some cataclysmic event but
actually we believe they could be part
of the fundamental building blocks of
the solar system and maybe maybe of life
on earth they one of the tests they'd
like to do is to see whether or not
there are any amino acids in the Comets
I mean they've actually been doing
analysis of this for a few months
because it it's not that you know you
don't send the spacecraft off is come
shooting in at 55,000 kilometers an hour
plus one and then slow it down and slow
down sort of overnight it's taken months
to do this but that means they've been
able to take pictures and actually we've
got luck they've got lots of detectors
on the spacecraft and so they've already
been taking images of the dust that's
coming off of the the temperature of it
that the lights the the coma which makes
up the surrounds the the comet one of
the unusual things I was reading about
is that's been getting lighter and
darker over a six-week period and I
don't think people really expecting that
but and one of the things that tickled
me was that they've been getting water
they're detecting water vapor coming off
and it's coming off at about the the
rate of a can of coca-cola a second you
know in the equivalent of the volume and
it's about 300 milliliters a second
coming off